we are told that a conservation group
with a long-term goal of preserving
species believes that all at-risk
species will disappear when land
inhabited by those species is developed
it has an opportunity to purchase land
in an area about to be developed
the group has a choice of creating one
large nature preserve with an area of 45
square kilometers and containing 70
at-risk species
or five small nature preserves each with
an area of three square kilometers and
each containing 16 at-risk species
unique to that preserve
which choice would you recommend and why
and there's some interesting data here
here's it looks like some data they have
gathered for different islands and we
have their areas and then this is the
number of species at risk in 1990 and
then the species extinct by 2000 and so
we can see for these various islands we
can see their areas and the proportion
that got extinct
and it looks like they're plotted on
this scatter plot now be very careful
when you look at this because look at
the two axes it is the vertical axis is
the proportion extinct in 2000 so it's
these numbers but the horizontal axis
isn't just straight up area it's the
natural log of the area and why did they
do this well notice when you make the
horizontal axis the natural log of the
area it looks like there's a linear
relationship but be clear it's a linear
relationship between the natural log of
the area and proportion extinct in 2000
but the reason why it's valuable to do
this type of transformation is now we
can apply our tools of linear regression
to think about what would be the
proportion extinct for the 45 square
kilometers versus for the five small
three kilometer islands so pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
on your own and they give us the
regression data for a line that fits
this data
all right now let's work through it
together and to make some space
because all of it is already plotted
right over here and we have our
regression data so the regression line
we know it's slope and y-intercept the
y-intercept is right over here 0.28996
so 0.2 this is let's see one two three
four five so two eight
nine nine six it's almost two nine so
it's going to be right over here would
be the y-intercept and its slope is
negative
0.05 approximately and i could eyeball
it it probably is going to look
something
something like this that's the
regression line
or another way to think about it is the
regression line tells us in general the
proportion
proportion and i'll just say proportion
shorthand for proportion extinct is
going to be equal to
our y-intercept 0.28996
minus
minus 0.053
and we have to be careful here you might
be tempted to say times the area but no
the horizontal axis here is the natural
log of the area
times the natural log of the area
and so we can use this equation for both
scenarios to think about what is going
to be the proportion that it gets that
we would expect to get extinct in either
situation and then how many actual
species will get extinct and then the
one that maybe has fewer species that
get extinct is maybe the best one or the
one that the more that we can preserve
is maybe the best one and so let's look
at the two scenarios
so the first scenario
is the 45 square kilometer island and
this is just one so times one
and so what is going to be the
proportion
proportion that we would expect to go
extinct based on this regression what's
going to be 0.28996
minus 0.05323
times the natural log of 45.
and if we want to know the actual number
that go extinct so number
extinct
extinct would be equal to the proportion
would be equal to the proportion
times
how many let's see the 45 square
kilometers and it contains 70 at-risk
species so times our 70 species and so
we can get our calculator out to figure
that out
so this is the proportion we would
expect to go extinct in the 45 square
kilometer island based on our linear
regression so this would be equal to so
it looks like almost nine percent and if
we want to figure out the actual number
we would expect to go extinct we would
just multiply that times the number of
species on that island so times
70
and we get so approximately about 6.11
so let me write that down
so
this is going to be approximately
6.11 so we could say there would be
approximately if we let's just say six
extinct
this is all very approximate
extinct
and approximately 64 saved
now let's think about the other scenario
let's think about the scenario where we
have five small nature preserves so it's
going to be three square kilometers
times five islands
and we're going to just do the same
exercise our proportion
that goes extinct is going to be 0.28996
that's just the y-intercept for our
regression line
minus
0.05323 and they have a negative sign
there because we have a negative slope
and this is not just times the area it's
times the natural log of the area it's
going to be
three square kilometers
three
square kilometers and then our number
extinct our number
extinct
is going to be equal to our proportion
that we will calculate in the line above
times let's see
five small nature preserves each with an
area of three square kilometers and each
containing 16 at-risk species
so 5 times 16 if each island has 16 and
there's 5 islands that's going to be 5
times 16 is 80. so times 80. so let's
figure out what this is get the
calculator out again
and we are going to get so this is going
to be the proportion it's a much higher
proportion and then we'll multiply that
times our number of species so times 80
to figure out how many species will go
extinct and we have here it's
approximately
18.52
so this is approximately 18.52
so another way to think about it is
we're going to have approximately well
if we round let's just say 19 extinct
19 extinct and then if we have 19
extinct how many we're going to save
we're going to have 61 saved 61
saved and even if you said 18 and a half
here and 61.5 here on either measure
the 45 square the big island is better
you're going to have fewer species that
are extinct and more that are saved so
which choice would you recommend and why
i'd recommend the one large island
because you're going to save you would
expect to save more species and you
would expect that fewer going to get
extinct based on this linear regression